présenter d'autres invités en quelques
mots jean marc jancovici bonsoir bonsoir
et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
alors moi en général je reprends la très
courte présentation twitter de la mairie
de très courtes
alors vous allez particulièrement court
donc là un petit peu étoffés
particulièrement courte parce que vous
dites juste ingénieur conseil en hashtag
énergie est activement hashtag
transition énergétique
puis après vous renvoyer vers vos
différents mais dire j'ai dit ça - sur
twitter c'est ça c'est possible c'est
pas moi qui gère ma page fin mon compte
twitter
c'est une question comment vous trouvez
tout le temps pour être aussi présent
sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez été nommé à la fin à la fin
d'année dernière au haut conseil pour le
climat vous êtes un inlassable
pédagogues des questions liées à
l'énergie
en gros pour vous les questions liées à
la transition énergétique ou à l'énergie
globalement sont clés sont vraiment la
clé c'est le coeur de quasiment de tous
les enjeux puisque quand on lit quand on
vous lit quand on vous suit
c'est une clé de lecture de notre monde
d'autres civilisations jeu si je n'ai
qu'un livre à recommander ce serait le
changement climatique expliqué à ma
fille que je montre là bon il est très
corner il ya des pages dedans mais c'est
un livre la nouvelle édition augmentée
au seuil
un livre que je vous recommande vraiment
surtout si vous n'êtes pas comme moi un
économiste ou un technicien d'énergie
c'est fascinant parce qu'on
al'impression bientôt comprendre et donc
mission mission réussie en tout cas pour
vous parce que parce que parce que c'est
quand même pas si simple de transmettre
ce que ce que vous dites au jour le jour
un autre livre également dormez
tranquilles jusqu'en 2100 et autre
malentendu sur le climat et l'énergie
mais globalement suivez notre invité sur
son blog
jancovici points comme et puis sur sur
vos réseaux sociaux
donc c'est pas vous qui vous occupez de
votre page twitter de votre [ __ ] n'ont
ni la page facebook qu'il compte twitter
la page facebook un jour
une de mes filles qui al'âge de
s'intéresser à facebook à cette époque
là encore aujourd'hui le reste me dis
tiens tu as créé une page facebook
alors je la regarde avec des yeux ronds
à 10 rabon pardon excusez moi j'ai une
page facebook et des tum apprend quelque
chose
alors en fait non c'est quelqu'un qui a
créé la page facebook qui porte mon nom
et qui avait comme objectif à l'époque
le fait de diffuser des informations ou
qui étaient dans la ligne des choses
dont je vais m'intéresser
j'ai pris contact avec lui et je lui dis
bah c'est super merci beaucoup
j'ai juste deux ou trois petits souhait
donc en fait sur la page facebook il est
explicitement écrit que c'est pas moi
qui la gère que c'est géré dans l'esprit
de diffuser des informations qui aident
les gens à comprendre et réfléchir donc
il ya toute une équipe qui s'occupe de
ça qui est emmenée par deux personnes
qui s'appelle jean-pierre dieterle à 1
joël leconte qui qui gère cette cette
page et il est bien précisé sur la page
que c'est pas moi après ils ont asservi
le compte twitter à la page facebook
donc c'est ni plus ni moins un mois
puisque les deux vont ensemble
le seul réseau que je gère en direct
c'est lyndine mais les deux autres je
les gère pas en direct mais donc je vais
voir de temps en temps à la fois pour
apprendre quelque chose plus que c'est
pas moi qui le gère et puis pour
vérifier qu'il n'y a pas de débordements
alors je crains pas beaucoup les
débordements dans l'information publiée
mais temps en temps dans les
commentaires moi j'ai toujours souhaité
que ça reste entre gens qui ont envie de
discuter et pas de se taper dessus et
que par ailleurs ça reste dans l'esprit
de la vulgarisation qui est celle qui me
paraît pertinente
donc là on gros la pédagogie du débat
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai eu extrêmement
peu de mauvaise surprise soit dit en
passant c'est vrai que sur les thèmes
qui vous travail au jour le jour
oui on voit pas mal de dérives dans les
commentaires notamment ça s'est très
vite fait de voir des gens ces sujets
assez pasionaria quelques sujets assez
passionnel dans ce pays alors
l'immigration la fiscalité est pire dans
l'énergie en un qui déchaîne les
passions c'est le exactement
l'opposition nucléaire renouvelable
électrique voilà celui là c'est un sujet
aussi dans lequel ça tourne vite au nom
d'oiseau on a une question rituelle ici
dans ces rendez vous des futurs une
question que nous av
vous avez donné andré brahic
astrophysicien qui étaient ici qui me
disais moi le but de ma vie c'est de
pouvoir expliquer le système solaire un
enfant de sept ans est bon il avait à
l'époque 73 ou 74
il disait je n'y arrive toujours pas
alors que c'était déjà pas d un but de
ma vie c'est de faire le clown il le
faisait magnifiquement bien on est
d'accord mais je pense que c'était le le
sou but en dessous comment vous
expliquer ce que vous faites dans la vie
un enfant de 7 ans vous a alors jusqu'à
maintenant les rares fois où on me
demande ce que je fais comme métier
je suis obligé d'utiliser une carte wet
parce que je sais toujours pas je
pourrais dire je suis un comptable du
carbone j'avais les gens vont me dire ah
bon j'ai rien gagné comme j'ai gagné
comme explication il m'arrive de temps
en temps devant de sortir en disant je
m'occupe des valeurs du monde ça déjà on
se comprend un peu mieux m'arrive de
dire tout bêtement je fais du conseil
mais enfin bon c'est quand même un truc
un peu vague 2faites j'appartiens à une
âge appartient comme beaucoup de gens
fassent comme au soudan
comme beaucoup de gens dans mon secteur
il ya plein de trucs qui sont un peu
émergents et donc à part si vous parlez
un public d'initiés les autres si vous
avez besoin de passer par un quart
d'heure d'explication avant de leur
expliquer ce que vous faites alors en
fait c'est vrai dans tous les métiers
qui ont une forte composante technique
c'est pareil je veux dire vous pouvez
faire des métiers qui sont extrêmement
compliquées par exemple vous pouvez être
un soudeur et faire des trucs très
compliqué si vous êtes un soudeur
plongeurs et que vous faites des
soudures à 150 m 2 par 150 mètres de
fond c'est pas évident expliqué non plus
voilà on comprend que ce n'est pas comme
quand vous êtes en train de réparer la
grille en fer forgé votre jardin quoi
donc le il ya plein de métiers
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont devenus très
technique d'une manière générale le bien
on fait partie au sens large
après il est sûr une préoccupation
émergentes donc ça fait un deuxième
élément de difficultés pour le
raccrocher à quelque chose qui parle aux
gens voilà donc effectivement c'est une
difficulté est face à un enfant de 7 ans
le plus vraisemblable c'est que à la
différence du regretté andré brahic moi
je devrais m'en tirer par une pirouette
sans faire le clown clown pour le
faisons bon alors pour nous aider à
entrer dans le vif du sujet un autre hit
ul c'est la revue de presse concocté
cette fois ci comme à l'accoutumée par
jérémy et coralie on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
il y a quelques jours le parlement
britannique a adopté une motion
déclarant l'urgence climatique et
environnementale un article du 2 mai
paru sur le site us bec erika revient
sur cette action plus symbolique
effective mais qui nous rappelle la
nécessité de réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et nous renvoie aux
engagements pris par de nombreux pays
lors de la cop 21 en 2015 mais jusqu'ici
non tenues comme le mentionne un édito
du monde le 30 avril
la principale piste du gouvernement
français pour soutenir ces objectifs
reposer sur une fiscalité verte qu'il
n'a pas su faire passer
et pour cause la fiscalité écologique
pose un redoutable problème d'équité
pour détourner l'usagé des énergies les
plus polluantes
elle se doit de frapper fort et se
faisant pénaliser les plus faibles et
les moins mobiles
elle aggrave la fracture entre les
mondialisé qui prennent l'avion sans
acquitter de surcoûts écologique et les
assignés à résidence qui n'ont d'autres
moyens que de payer l'essence plus cher
le site liberation.fr décortique quant à
lui la loi énergie et climat présenté le
30 avril au conseil des ministres entre
fermeture à court terme des centrales à
charbon révision de la part du nucléaire
dans le mix énergétique et pérennisation
du haut conseil pour le climat des
jalons sont posés sont toutefois
satisfaire les ong
car des dérogations sont déjà envisagés
pour maintenir l'activité de certaines
centrales à charbon que la réduction de
la part du nucléaire a été retardé de
dix ans et que le haut conseil pour le
climat n'a pas été dotées de pouvoirs
contraignants
c'est la grande hypocrisie oui oui on va
faire de l'énergie verte
mais on continue à faire du nucléaire
oui oui on va faire des voitures
électriques mais on continue à produire
des voitures thermiques
on ne passe pas un autre système ou
créés juste de nouveaux marchés c'est
avec ces mots à lire et écouter sur
france inter point fr que l'auteur
jérémy pichon envoie au placard la
notion de croissance verte prônée par le
gouvernement et plus généralement par
les politiques européennes
mais alors que faire il ne s'agit pas de
culpabiliser mais de responsabiliser
si l'individu ne décide pas dans son
quotidien de changer les choses et de se
mobiliser
le changement n'arrivera pas les
politiciens qu'on a aujourd'hui en
europe sont ceux que l'on mérite
alors comme les élections européennes
approchent invite les internautes à se
pencher sur un article du site oui
demain paru le 30 avril qui synthétise
les différentes propositions des
candidats français en matière d'écologie
banques européennes du climat green new
deal taxe kérosène de quoi y voir plus
clair et aider à se positionner
finissons enfin avec une prescription
culturel à lire sur télérama.fr qui
invite à regarder le documentaire de
jean robert viallet l'homme a mangé la
terre en analysant les phases de
l'industrialisation le film se penche
sur ces moments où l'humanité s'est
engagé sur une voie décarbonés avant de
faire demi tour
à voir et à revoir sur arte.tv bon ben
moi j'ai plus qu'à renouveler mon
ordonnance d'anxiolytiques à jérémy je
crois qu'il va falloir que je te parle
des industries pharmaceutiques
maintenant
[Musique]
merci jérémy coralie un petit rebond
jean marc jancovici sur ce que vous avez
entendu de l'urgence climatique à tous
ces projets
vous qui peuvent paraître fou alors un
truc qui nous ramène ce qui a été dit
juste avant c'est qu'on parle d'urgence
climatique
l'urgence climatique est causé par les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le domaine énergétique
les émissions les énergies qui sont en
cause c'est le charbon le pétrole gaz
j'ai entendu charbon j'ai pas entendu
pétrole j'ai pas entendu gaz par contre
le retour du nucléaire qui est un truc
en dehors du débat climatique deux fois
voilà donc c'est très symptomatique de
ce que je disais tout à l'heure on adore
revenir au sein d'autres sujets préférés
pour s'en payer même si il est en dehors
de du scope après il faut bien voir
aussi que nous sommes tous schizophrène
donc on a beau jeu de reproché au
gouvernement de ne pas trancher nos
contradictions à notre place mais enfin
je connais plein de militants du climat
qui adore prendre l'avion pour aller aux
quatre coins de la planète
les militants des ong les premiers je
connais plein de gens qui militent pour
le climat et qu'ils n'accepteraient pas
l'idée de faire des sacrifices
personnels qui sont ceux justement dont
ils disent qu'il faut les faire chez les
autres enfin bref donc est en démocratie
c'est le charme de ce régime politique
vous n'avez pas de pouvoir qui tranchent
vos contradictions à votre place il sait
pas faire ça oui le fait mal donc vous
pouvez lui demander tout et son
contraire
du coup ce qui se passera c'est que ceux
qui gagnent le plus fort sont entendus
sur la préoccupation du moment et vous
obtenez pas la cohérence
voilà c'est juste ça la petite remarque
que j'ai effectivement on pointe du
doigt un vrai problème le problème de la
pédagogie le problème de la de la
connaissance finalement du partage de la
connaissance
oui alors c'est un double problème qui
est un problème de la de la pédagogie de
du sujet de quoi on parle il ya un truc
qui est un truisme mais vous ne savez
pas résoudre un problème que vous n'êtes
pas capables d'expliciter aliments donc
si vous n'êtes pas capable de poser de
problème la probabilité pour que le
réseau levier à part elle est aussi
forte que gagner à la roulette
vous n'êtes pas à l'abri d'une bonne
surprise mais c'est à peu près tout ce
que vous pouvez espérer et donc ça c'est
un premier sujet ça demande du temps
parce que encore une fois comme je le
disais tout à l'heure les problèmes de
ce monde la demande des techniques donc
les problèmes de ce monde sont des
problèmes qui s'exprime rarement
rapidement il y avait un très bon papier
je sais pas si je vais l'appeler d'un de
vos confrères mais d'un homme
remarquable ça fait sylvestre huet
il n'y a pas longtemps qui expliquait
avec le drame des démocraties modernes
c'est qu' aucun électeur ne possède dans
sa cervelle la capacité à comprendre la
totalité du monde qui l'entourent et
pour autorise le pouvoir tout choisir et
pourtant il veut pouvoir avoir un avis
sur tout donc le or il ya deux siècles
ou trois siècles ce que disait très bien
ce papier c'est que tout honnête homme
comme on disait à l'époque était capable
d'approcher avec ses seules sens la
quasi-totalité des techniques de
l'époque on était capable d'approcher
avec ses seules sens à peu près ce que
c'était qu'un poêle à bois un une forge
ou un engrenage
voilà on était capable de comprendre ça
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une personne au
monde qui est capable de comprendre le
fonctionnement de la totalité des objets
qui l'entourent pas une donc en fait on
est on est rentré dans un monde dans
lequel si vous faites pas confiance à
des tiers pour gérer à votre place vous
en sortez pas et au moment où arrivent
les contraintes et du cool envie de ne
plus faire confiance à tout le monde
parce que voyez bien qu'un truc qui va
pas vous avez énormément de mal à savoir
qui vous pouvez faire confiance à qui
vous pouvez pas faire confiance et dans
cette affaire-là
pour en revenir à la revue de presse les
médias aujourd'hui sont dépassés par la
tâche qui devrait être la leur qui
serait celle d'apporter des
éclaircissements et des clarifications
et le plus souvent il n'apporte que de
la confusion mais c'est juste le reflet
du fait qu'ils sont aussi perdus que les
autres et vous dites même à l'intérieur
de ce livre le changement climatique
expliqué ma fille que les médias
finalement passe beaucoup plus de temps
à parler notamment de quelques
alternatives type photovoltaïque éolien
alors ça représente pour notre île ce
dans la transition il se focalise sur ce
qu'il croit comprendre au lieu de ce
faux collier de 2
d'essayer d'arriver à quelque chose où
ils font la pédagogie encore une fois du
système dans son ensemble du problème
dans son ensemble et pour le dire
autrement il parle de ce qu'il croit
comprendre et non pas de ce qui est
important sauf que le tiers de confiance
ils sont où maintenant c'est une c'est
tout c'est toute la question
beaucoup ne savent pas où ils sont alors
beaucoup de gens considèrent que le
tiers de confiance il est proche de lui
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans les
périodes troublées on a tendance à voir
le repli sur soi alors le repli sur soi
peut prendre plusieurs formes
c'est le repli sur le local voyez qu'en
ce moment il n'y a que pour le local
alors à divers échelons les élus locaux
disent y'en a que pour nous les élus
nationaux 10 l'europe ça nous emmerde
et puis il y en a également
et l'autre forme de communautarisme
aujourd'hui qui a été permis justement
par la technique c'est les communautés
qui se reforment sur les réseaux sociaux
donc en fait vous assemblez avec des
gens qui vont ensemble parce que cela
vous rassure mais du coup vous comprenez
pas le reste du monde
on va vous le comprenez plus
difficilement les bulles de filtres ou
info oui exactement donc vous vous c'est
ça c'est ça en drôle mais ça ne vous
avance pas beaucoup pour arriver à
comprendre ce qui fait pas partie de
votre univers familier après du coup ils
ont donc là on parle des médias on parle
des communautés prose de dos
historiquement il ya quand même eu des
tiers de confiance normalement
l'éducation nationale les souks l'ific
l'école d'éducation nationale devrait
jouer ce rôle normalement c'est de vous
donner les bases avec des information
réfutée émanant de tiers de confiance
qui vous permettent de vous y retrouver
dans la vie ça normalement la base de
l'enseignement le monde évolue trop vite
malheureusement pour que l'enseignement
pu suivre un vrai sujet et puis les
enseignants forme les élèves mais qui
forment les enseignants quand le monde
évolue bon un vrai sujet ou si vous avez
des tiers de confiance éventuellement
dans l' expertise mais là vous avez les
meilleurs ennemis des expériences et le
monde politique
vous avez entendu un nombre incalculable
de fois le débat ne doit pas être
confisqué par les experts
quand vous entendez ça c'est une façon
de dire ils n'ont pas voix au chapitre
s'il commence à s'exprimer
ça veut dire qu'ils vont confisquer le
débat je suis désolé moi pour avoir un
débat sur le traitement que j'ai envie
de suivre je préfère qu avoir affaire à
un médecin qui sache de quoi il parle
donc le l'expertisé je vois pas en quoi
ça me prive de mon libre arbitre
au contraire ça m'aide à l'exprimer
entre des choses qui sont comment dire
ça m'aide à me retrouver dans un univers
dans lequel j'ai supprimé tout ce qui
était invraisemblable et donc je vais
gagner du temps et de l'efficacité
c'est pas du tout d'être dépossédés de
mon libre arbitre sauf que comme le
politique n'a pas lui-même le temps de
comprendre toute la technique s'ils sont
remis à l'expert quelque part il a
l'impression qu'on me prive d'une partie
de son pouvoir plus à mon avis qu'ils
emmerdent que les médias ne joue pas non
plus bien ce rôle en france alors c'est
pas vrai dans tous les pays mais en
france ils sont particulièrement
désarmés face à la complexité technique
et alors j'ai une petite anecdote il se
trouve que j'ai été amené plusieurs fois
faire des conférences dans des écoles de
journalisme et à chaque fois j'ai
demandé au responsable des études qui
étaient là s'il y avait dans les
formations des journalistes
l'apprentissage de règles de processus
pour s'y retrouver dans des domaines
techniques auxquelles on comprend rien
parce qu'il ya des règles de processus
on peut donner des règles de processus
et si on les suit on limite assez
largement la quantité de caudry qu'on
peut raconter
sané a pris nulle part c'est aussi
quelque chose qui n'aide pas les médias
à jouer leur rôle et du coup vous avez
des déviances comme celle que vous venez
d'évoquer à propos de claire nouvian
c'était comme on n'est pas que comme on
n'a pas le bagage technique pour
discuter du fond alors on s'attaque à la
forme on s'attaque à la forme on
simplifie 12 en attendant cela grésy
case donc l'agressivité journalistique
qui face à l'expert n'est rien d'autre
que la preuve de son incompétence
technique sur le fond donc ok on a
besoin d'experts l'expert est très vite
brocardé ou mis dans des cases le
politique le politique à tendance assez
bon quand il est honnête
tous ne sont pas l'expert quand il est
honnête il essaye de faire la part des
choses entre ce qui relève du fait
observables et ce qui relève de sa
propre conviction qu'ils le font pas
tous normalement
en tout cas vous êtes en droit de lui
demander si vous êtes en droit de lui
demander si je vous dis que la terre est
ronde
ça relève d'un faits observables
réfutable ou si ça relève de ma
conviction vous avez le droit de le
demander d'où je tiens l'information je
vous donne en vous lisant je me dis
qu'il ya aussi quelque chose d'assez
fondamentale il faudrait juste qu'on
arrête déjà de confondre climat et météo
par exemple et ce avant de la prendre il
part
on a besoin nulle part parce que par
ailleurs nos sens nous induisant
confusion forêt ont rappelé qu on a beau
être très intelligent avoir fait des
micros des tables des émissions de
télévision passionnante
on reste quand même des animaux et les
animaux ils pilotent leurs pilotes leur
vie en faisant confiance à leur sens il
reste heureusement qu historiquement
c'est ce qu'on a fait parce que si on
n'avait pas fait confiance à notre sens
sont en hausse ans on aura tous été
bouffés par les tigre à dents de sabre à
dents de sabre table et joli lapsus et
on serait pas là donc le heureusement
qu'on a fait confiance à nos sens et ce
qui nous permet de réagir à l'instant
mais du coup quand on a affaire un
problème qui n'est accessible que par
l'abstraction et le changement
climatique c'est le cas parce que ça
n'est accessible que par des moyennes
moyennes c'est une autre mais une
abstraction une projection dans le futur
projection dans le futur c'est une
abstraction donc ça n'est accessible que
par des abstractions et du coup c'est
inaccessible à nos sens si on fait pas
un considérable effort sur soi pour
essayer de comprendre ce que ça veut
dire
c'est un domaine dans lequel on peut pas
procéder par l'expérience dire qu'on n'a
pas de données d'observation sur 427
humanité qui aurait essayé un changement
climatique plus ou moins importants et
c'est comme ça on se dit bon se pilote
par l'expérience
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement déroutant pour des animaux
qui font confiance à leur sens et qui
par ailleurs n'ont aucune n'y a aucun
précédent dans l'histoire qui permet
justement par l'essence de voir ce que
ça donne et la confusion météo et climat
en est une en est une conséquence
c'est-à-dire que quand on vous parle de
quelques degrés de la variation de la
moyenne
vous savez pas ce que c'est qu'une
moyenne dont ce que vous savez ces
quelques degrés de la variation de la
température là où vous êtes dans la
journée voilà ça vous comprenez que vous
comprenez que c'est pas grave puisque
vous êtes vous êtes vous êtes fait entre
guillemets enfin darwin vous a
sélectionné pour que vous sachiez assez
bien résisté à ça ce que vous serez
vivant à la fin de la journée la
température dehors à varier de quelques
degrés et bien du coup vous minimiser la
gravité d'une variation de la moyenne
tout simplement parce que c'est pas
accessible à vos sens de comprendre ce
que c'est qu'une moyenne
pourquoi on persiste à parler climat et
qu'on ne parle pas de mots qui parlent
plus comme pollution ou comme
biodiversité là on en parle en ce moment
en l'occurrence vous avez
la réponse implicite dans votre question
est parfaitement fondé mon expérience
dans le domaine professionnel qui est
donc si je fais plus qu'expliquer un
enfant de 7 ans qui consiste à essayer
de trouver toute action qui est à
l'intersection de moins de carbone est
quelque chose d'intéressant pour les
gens qui je parle c'est ça mon domaine
donc quand tu parles à une entreprise
j'essaye de trouver qu'est ce qui peut
être intéressant pour elle à
l'intersection de ce qu'elle fait et
moins de carbone c'est pas toujours
facile parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'activités qui ne survivent pas à moins
de carbone même l'essentiel mais c'est
ça eh bien je me suis rendu compte avec
l'expérience que le climat ce que vous
savez faire au mieux
c'est qu'il soit un coût bénéfices de
long terme d'une action qui est
intéressante pour autre chose
donc en fait passer à l'action sur le
plan de la baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre si vous forcer à trouver
tous les trucs qui sont intéressants à
court terme pour l'intérêt égoïste de
quelqu'un et qui par ailleurs ont comme
bénéfice de faire baisser les émissions
c'est vraiment trouver les leviers pour
mais c'est comme ça mais je ne connais
personne qui est fait aujourd'hui
quelque chose de construit de
considérablement contraignant pour le
bénéfice du climat avec que des
inconvénients à court terme tu connais
personne
d'où l'intérêt d'expliciter plus d'où
l'intérêt de parler plus du vivant de la
biodiversité
alors d'où l'intérêt surtout de
comprendre à chaque fois que vous avez
affaire à quelqu'un qui est en face de
vous et qui a une activité qui est ce
qu'elle est ou est ce que vous pouvez
trouver un bénéfice de court terme lié
au fait qu'ils s'occupent correctement
du climat d'ailleurs on a parlé des
gilet jaune
je vais prendre un exemple si les gilet
jaune vous êtes capable en même temps de
leur dire je vais vous donner un moyen
de vous déplacer qui vous coûte un peu
moins cher voire beaucoup moins cher que
la voiture individuelle
je vais vous le proposer dans le même
temps je vais vous je vais prendre un
peu plus cher la voiture individuelle
mais je vous aurais déjà proposé une
alternative à ce moment vous pouvez
espérer une bascule est l'un des
bénéfices de court terme de la bascule
c'est que vous économisez de l'argent on
comprendre entre encore plus précis
1 km en voiture ça vous coûte un peu
plus de 20 centimes si vous mettez
l'amortissement de la voiture
l'entretien l'assurance aux carburants
etc
lequel carburant ne fait que 15 % soit
dit en passant si vous faites un
kilomètre en but un passager kilomètre
en bus c'est 7 centimes
donc toute personne qui dit j'ai plus de
voiture et je vais au travail en bus
indépendamment du fait que il a d'autres
problèmes à régler et éventuellement
savoir comment il fait ses courses
comment il part en week-end s'il a les
moyens de partir ils gagnent de l'argent
à faire ça quelqu'un qui covoiturent
s'il arrive à trouver un covoitureur
parce qu'il faut partir à la même heure
pour aller au même endroit est arrivé à
nevers pas si simple que ça eh bien il
est ce pareil on partage à deux un coup
alors qu'avant on assumer tout seul
donc il ya un gain financier à l'arrivée
la votre bénéfice de court terme c'est
pas le climat c'est le gain financier
dont vous habiller d'un bénéfice de long
terme quelque chose qui a une motivation
de court terme
donc quel que soit le sujet auquel vous
vous attaquez si vous trouvez pas un
bénéfice de court terme vous aller nulle
part
et l'erreur qu'a fait le gouvernement
avec la façon dont ils pensaient que la
taxe carbone dont je suis par ailleurs
un fervent défenseur allait régler le
problème
madame lagarde a encore dit la semaine
dernière c'est le moyen le plus efficace
qu'on est d'agir non c'est un outil
d'une panoplie à partir du moment où les
gens ont une alternative
s'ils n'ont pas d'alternative ils font
ce qui se passe avec les jaunes et ça ce
mécanisme il est il est humain
évidemment je suis il fonctionne à
l'échelle des états l'échelle d'un
continent tout le monde quand vous êtes
corner risée vous êtes agressif
du coup le giec ils auront beau
continuer d'émettre des rapports et de
faire d'accord tous les allogènes
prescriptif sur les solutions
c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre le
giec représente déjà un tour de force
dans le monde scientifique
c'est d'avoir fait un guichet unique
d'accès à l'information qui transcende
les disciplines prises une par une
c'est à dire que en fait des
climatologues ça n'existe pas ça n'a
jamais existé dans le domaine du climat
vous avez des dizaines de spécialités
qui concourent à comprendre ce qui se
passe jean jouzel il a démarré sa
carrière professionnelle en année en
faisant des analyses isotopiques dans
les grêlons de glace il c'est pas du
tout ça fait pas de lui un week-end au
log ça fait pas lui un astronome ça fait
pas de lui un océanographe et ça fait
pas de lui un spécialiste biogéochimiste
spécialiste du cycle du carbone d'accord
alors toutes les spécialités que je
viens d'évoquer est encore plein
d'autres sont nécessaires pour
comprendre ce qui se passe dans le
système climatique et proposer une vue
de son évolution possible si les hommes
commencent à agir donc le giec est un
tour de force qui consiste à avoir mis
dans une même barque des dizaines de
spécialités différentes et leur avoir
posé presque la question du début s'est
raconté un enfant de 7 ans alan
l'occurrence au plus tôt lui rajouter 1
0 mais rajouter explique est un grand
enfant de 30 ans fascinée par les
gadgets technos enfin vraiment enfants
de quoi il retourne quand on s'occupe du
changement que faire quand on parle du
changement climatique et j'insiste dans
le monde scientifique l'a prié fait
d'une juxtaposition de spécialités très
pointu qui ne se parlent pas et bien
c'est ça en tant que tel c'est déjà un
tour de force après le giec au moment où
il a été créé il était évidemment écrit
qu'il ne devait pas être prescriptif
donc le giec ne devait pas dire vous
allez faire ceci puis vous allez faire
cela et soit dit en passant je vois pas
comment on peut être prescrite titre
dans ce domaine parce qu'au fond le
débat qui est posée par le changement
climatique c'est un débat fondamental
qui est est ce que je m'en vais au
régime pour durer ou est-ce que j'ai
aucune envie de me mettre au régime
et advienne que pourra c'est ça la
question qui est posée
vous n'avez pas de réponse scientifique
à cette question vous avez une réponse
éthique
vous avez une réponse morale vous avez
une réponse affective éventuellement
mais vous avez absolument aucune réponse
scientifique à cette question donc si la
communauté des hommes dit on a envie de
durer à ce moment faut accepter la
contrepartie qui est qu'on va devoir se
mettre au régime et pas qu'un peu
si on dit le régime
un autre jour à ce moment ça durera pas
et ça a déjà commencé par petites
touches à ne pas durer
c'est juste ça c'est juste ça le la
question posée et les scientifiques
n'ont pas à notre place de même que
votre médecin vous d'y fumer c'est pas
bon pour la santé c'est pas lui qui va
se mettre
arrêter de fumer à votre place et la
contrainte vient par la pression donc là
en l'occurrence pour la pression des
peuples par lapin se rend à l'impression
des auteurs en démocratie n'est rien
d'autre qu'une qu'une contrainte fin
comment dire n'est rien d'autre qu'une
préférence qu'on exprime ce qui est
important pour les gens comme moi c'est
que les peuples comprennent les termes
du choix d'accès que les gens
comprennent
ne pas agir voilà ce que ça suppose ou
ce que ça implique agir voilà ce que ça
implique
et puis comme disait l'autre après je
choisis ton camp camarade donc moi ce
que j'essaye d'expliquer c'est que en
fait ne pas agir
ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens parce que
d'une manière ou d'une autre il y aura
un effort à faire
donc ou bien je fais l'effort en
l'organisant ou bien je ne fait pas
l'effort en l'organisant et à ce moment
j'aurais un effort subit pas parce qu'on
deviendra vertueux plus tard parce que
le pétrole est épuisable que le charbon
est épuisable que le gaz est épuisable
et que le truc le plus épuisable de
touche là dedans c'est la stabilité des
sociétés humaines
donc quand le truc commence à être
attaquée de toute part ça se terminera
en boucherie
bon donc tellement sympathiques comme
perspective donc le donc l'idée qu'on va
hadji tam aeternam passer à travers les
mailles du filet c'est une idée que je
combats parce que je pense que
malheureusement c'est pas possible
après les termes de l'effort il faut les
faire comprendre
est ce que j'essaye d'expliquer aussi
pour pas avoir peur des mots c'est que
de lutter contre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à la vitesse à laquelle
il faudrait le faire pour qu'on ait les
fameux 2° qu'il soit pas dépassée c'est
une économie guerre c'est pas juste on
va faire trois rapports développement
durable
installer une ruche sur le toit et faire
trois sommets où on explique mec de
planètes l'eyetoy n'est pas du tout dans
ces ordres de grandeur là il faut le
faire comprendre
il faut que les gens comprennent ce que
ça veut dire alors je ne souhaite pas la
guerre quand je dis économie de guerre
ça veut dire qu'on rentre dans des
systèmes dans lesquels une part de notre
liberté d'aujourd'hui n'existe plus ça
envahi le web on va laisser ça veut dire
est ce qu'on gagne donc cette part
disparaît mais ce qu'on gagne c'est
préserver d'autres choses qui sinon
disparaîtront aussi et on en revient à
l'idée toujours de pédagogie de et
certaines ont des consignes ans
exactement et c'est un arbitrage
c'est vraiment un arbitrage il n'ya pas
d'autre manière de présenter le sujet on
va passer en faire une petite pause avec
la avec margot qui va venir nous
rejoindre au plateau c'est la pause hors
d'oeuvre
[Musique]
margot rovereto ni jean marc jancovici
margot la responsable éditoriale du cube
est régulièrement elle vient nous nous
livrer un hors d'oeuvre un hors d'oeuvre
culturel margot c'est à toi alors en
penchant sur votre parcours j'ai vu que
vous aviez collaborer pour avec l'ademe
donc l' agence de l'environnement et de
la maîtrise de l'énergie pour la mise au
point du bilan carbone alors le bilan
carbone je le rappelle sera
comptabilisée à mesurer les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre dues à la
consommation en énergie d'un groupe ou
d'un individu
c'est un outil qui répond d'une certaine
manière aux besoins des hommes de
visualiser concrètement leur impact
écologique pour entreprendre une
quelconque mobilisation et étant donné
que la pollution atmosphérique relève
souvent du champ de l'invisible et étant
donné que les catastrophes écologiques
font partie majoritairement du registre
du prévisible
je me suis demandé si des artistes
avaient imaginé un système de
représentation de notre consommation en
énergie de ses excès et de ses
conséquences sur l'environnement et j'ai
trouvé un collectif d'artistes qui
s'appelle et est composé de helen evans
et de highco en scène dont le travail
consiste justement à représenter les
effets de la pollution et nos modes de
consommation en énergie donc ce duo
d'artistes travaillent en particulier
sur des installations et des
performances dans lequel il met en scène
des machines qui sont conçues pour
répondre à nos besoins en énergie donc
ça va des plateformes pétrolières aux
centrales électriques nucléaires les
voitures mais aussi tous les appareils
électriques du quotidien qui contribue
aussi à la pollution atmosphérique et
leur parti pris artistique c'est de
rendre visible et d'esthétiser la
pollution atmosphérique et les émissions
de co2 et donc je vous ai sélectionné
trois exemples pour illustrer mon propos
on le voit donc la première oeuvre
s'appelle prise en charge
donc elle montre une prise électrique
diffusantes de la fumée donc elle fait
partie d'une série d'oeuvres consacrées
aux catastrophes domestiques et
questionne
la pollution générée par la production
des objets que nous utilisons
quotidiennement donc sur voilà ce
deuxième exemple c'est plus évident
c'est la pollution liés aux voitures
donc ici on voit une porsche cayenne
dont le pot d'échappement ne libère pas
du co2 mais des plumes roses et enfin le
dernier
le dernier exemple c'est le projet nuage
vert donc il s'intéresse aux pollutions
industrielles et ici les artistes ont
projeté un rayon laser vert qui entoure
le nuage de fumée émis par une centrale
électrique et qui change de taille en
fonction de la consommation en énergie
des habitants donc pourquoi alors leur
démarche est intéressante parce que à
travers leurs oeuvres il ya une volonté
de lutter contre de cécité la première
cécité c'est l'impossibilité de voir ce
qui est invisible donc le co2 la
diffusion de particules polluantes
la mauvaise qualité de l'air par exemple
et la deuxième c'est cité c'est notre
aveuglement volontaire
la politique de l'autruche lorsque nous
savons mais que nous ne voulons pas voir
est ce que j'aime avec dans leur projet
c'est cette volonté de nous interpeller
deux l'ont forcé à regarder et à changer
notre perception sur un paysage que nous
avons intégré à force d'habitude et qui
ne nous choque plus et cela ça m'a
rappelé les paroles d'un être humain que
qu'on avait invité ici pour une
conférence sur la colonne au logis et
qui disait nous nous focalisons
aujourd'hui dans le seul quotidien et
nous perdons notre capacité à nous
étonner
or en matérialisant et en représentant
les problèmes environnementaux
ce duo d'artistes nos pousse justement a
retrouvé une certaine manière la vue et
à réfléchir à nos modes de consommation
[Musique]
jean marc jancovici un mot peut-être un
margon sur cette cécité notamment au dos
rond par les margaux je vais dire
quelque chose d'un peu plus large en
fait le les grands projets humains sont
toujours des projets dans lesquels on
exécute rationnellement quelque chose
qui à l'origine
nenê qu'affectif entre guillemets c'est
un désir est ce que est ce qu'il ya une
rationalité dans le fait de vouloir
faire un tel métier plutôt que tel autre
dans le fait de vouloir habiter à tel
endroit plutôt que tel autre où il ya
des éléments de rationalité mais
fondamentalement il ya aussi des désirs
qui ont l'art sa part normalement aux
émotions
tout ce que je pense que c'est important
à partir du moment où on pense que c'est
un sujet qui doit entraîner des gens de
ne pas parler qu'avec la raison parce
que malheureusement ou heureusement je
ne suis rien de tout ça ne suffit pas où
ça ne marche pas alors est ce que l'art
est la meilleure manière de parler je ne
sais pas il a pendant longtemps j'ai eu
un j'ai eu deux ou trois envies
alors qu'ils touchaient pas tant un art
statique j'ai envie de dire mais aussi
les mardis j'ai eu très envie une
dizaine d'années d'essayer de pousser
c'était après un fils qui s'appelle le
jour d'après j'ai pas ça vous dit
quelque chose
et j'avais une horrible j'avais eu
l'idée de faire un concept film le
concept film aurait été de faire un film
avec tous les canons de beauté est
habituel pour un film donc le bon et le
méchant l'histoire d'amour le traître
tout ce que vous voulez et dans laquelle
la partie scientifique concernant le
changement climatique aurait été
totalement irréprochable ce qui n'était
pas du tout le cas dans le jour d'après
il y avait des tas de trucs qui était
totalement invraisemblable sur le plan
physique et je me suis dit si on fait ça
ça veut dire que il ya une caisse de
résonance médiatique absolument
considérable qui est que tout physicien
à qui on demande son avis dit oui ça
c'est possible
voilà donc alors pas mon métier d'écrire
des scénarios
j'ai essayé d'avancer trempions dans une
direction en me disant si jamais sa mort
tant mieux puisqu'il aborde pas tant pis
pas grave je vais faire mon métier mais
je suis resté avec l'idée que ça fait
partie des choses qui auraient pu être
utiles parce que je vais prendre un
autre domaine dans le domaine de
l'informatique par exemple il ya un film
qui a fait énormément sur le débat sur
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
des trucs intelligents ou est ce qu'on
est en train de se fourrer dans la nasse
c'est terminator c'est un film message
quelque part tout le monde s'en souvient
enfin je veux dire voilà le fait qu'on
puisse construire nous mêmes
quelque chose qui va nous asservir
ça a été c'est un débat qui a été nourri
notamment pas que est nourri par ce film
donc le voilà donc j'avais j'avais
l'idée de d'aller un peu dans la même
voie sur le jeu donc je pense que c'est
important effectivement oui de faire
exister ce sujet là dans le monde
artistique
alors ce qui a été montré là c'est plus
loin de ma zone de confort pas vraiment
d'avis par contre dans le cinéma et la
bande dessinée j'étais intimement
persuadé que c'est quelque chose je
reste persuadé que c'est quelque chose
qui serait utile et du coup est ce que
vous diriez que un film comme le jour
d'après ou plein d'autres films
qui parle de catastrophe naturelle mais
pas forcément condamnés dans un réel
celui-là était contreproductif il a fait
l'effet exactement inverse et le voyez
et on dit est ce que ça peut ressembler
à ce qui peut se passer et vous êtes
capable de dire non parce que çà çà çà
çà et ce à un moment il ya un
hélicoptère qui est frigorifiée parce
qu'il ya de l'air qui descendent la
haute atmosphère
frustré il se trouve que quand vous
comprimer l'air ils se réchauffent tous
les gens qui ont actionné une pompe à
vélo le savent donc l'air qui quand ils
se comprime se refroidisse et contraire
c'est contraire aux lois de la physique
donc vous êtes déjà capable de dire ça
c'est impossible mais ces films du coup
devient de contre-productif et hulk ou
et du coup tous les gens vous disent pas
c'est un film donc ça c'est pas possible
donc les gens disent ah bon ce truc là
est pas possible mais on a présenté cela
comme une catastrophe climatique
possible hors du coup et la vérité bon
donc en fait une fois qu'on est passé
par là il ya un deuxième truc et le gulf
stream s'arrêtait en une semaine c'est
juste pas possible
le troisième truc qui est pas possible
dans le film c'est si vous arrêtez le
gulfstream ça vous en glace totalement
l'hémisphère nord c'est juste pas
possible non plus voilà donc vous avez
plein de trucs là dedans qui sont
totalement invraisemblable sur le plan
physique
donc de ce fait ce film à un moment il
devient un peu contre productif c'est
eric il enferme la représentation
artistique de la chose dans une
invraisemblance et margot a parlé de
cette cécité de cet aveuglement
volontaire vous dit très bien
l'intérieur du livre le changement
climatique expliqué ma fille vous
parlais justement de ce cette espèce de
solutions nice mme techno il y aura
toujours mais oui mais oui mais on y
arrivera parce qu'à la fin à la fin ça
va toujours jusqu'où ça va aller ça ça
s'est déjà arrêtée en fait ça s'est
arrêté une première fois à petite
vitesse au moment des chocs pétroliers
62 79 64 79 ça s'arrête une deuxième
fois de manière plus brutale depuis dix
ans on va dire
c'est à dire que nous sommes depuis
maintenant une dizaine d'années en perte
de contrôle accéléré sur ce qui se passe
dans le monde et la technologie ne peut
rien pour nous d'abord on a un premier
sujet qui est con et 7 milliards et demi
sur une planète qui a peut-être pas été
fait pour ça pas sûr qu'il y ait un
comment dire une échappatoire
technologique commode
nous sommes ensuite dans un monde qui
dépend d'un certain nombre de ressources
est ce qu'on a l'habitude de qualifier
comme étant des technologies accélère
plus tôt la consommation de ressources
plutôt que celle de la diminue il se
trouve qu'au chiffre project on a fait
un gros travail sur le numérique qui a
commencé il ya un an et demi le
numérique a la particularité d'être
particulièrement consommateurs de
ressources par dollar de valeur ajoutée
et particulièrement émetteurs de co2 par
dollar de valeur ajoutée en fait la
numérisation je vais le dire autrement
et en raccourci c'est une catastrophe
supplémentaire pour la pression
environnementale n'est pas du tout
quelque chose qui permet de partir dans
le bon sens donc en fait là il faut
renverser l'équation l'équation sais
vous vous donnez une contrainte absolue
sur le problème que vous voulez régler
et à ce moment ça vous dit c'est pas
franchissable c'est la règle que je me
fixe et à ce moment vous tirer le
meilleur parti de ce qui vous reste
c'est ce qui s'appelle de l'optimisation
sous contrainte dans le monde des
ingénieurs or là avec les nouvelles
technologies ont fait pas du tout de
l'optimisation sous contrainte ont fait
de l'optimisation sans contrainte
ce qui est tout à fait différent un
autre truc ne réglera pas la technologie
c'est la question du travail du reste le
on l'a un peu brocardé à l'époque de la
dernière présidentielle mais l'idée de
la taxation des robots de valls répond à
quelque chose qui est un vrai sujet qui
est à partir du moment où vous avez des
limites sur les ressources et sur
l'énergie qui vous limite l'activité
globale qui sont un facteur limitant de
l'activité économique dans son ensemble
d'activités humaines dans son ensemble
c'est assez facile de comprendre que
plus un dogme et productifs plus un
travailleur et productif et moins il ya
de la place pour beaucoup de
travailleurs donc dans un monde qui est
sous contraintes de ressources
malheureusement la clé de l'accès à
l'emploi c'est pas d'augmenter la
productivité du travail c de la b c ce
qui évidemment pèse aussi des
rémunérations il n'y a pas de mystère
c'est pas du tout aujourd'hui ce que
vous ont continué à penser finalement
que l'échappatoire par la technologie et
l'échappatoire pour la productivité vont
régler nos problèmes
moi je crois l'exact inverse
alors il ya une expression très en vogue
en ce moment qui s'appelle low tech
j'aime pas tellement cette expression
parce qu'en fait c'est une eye
intelligent en steaks
c'est à dire que justement vous vous
êtes un exercice qui est très
contraignant pour l'esprit parce que
vous ne résolvez pas les problèmes en
vous aidant d'une consommation de
ressources accrues ça j'ai envie de dire
c'est la façon facile de résoudre les
problèmes
vous êtes obligés de tirer le meilleur
parti d'un truc est globalement
insuffisant c'est beaucoup plus dur
c'est beaucoup plus dur c'est beaucoup
plus challengeant sur le plan à la fois
intellectuelle et morale parce que
comment est ce que vous répartissez la
pénurie c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
répartir la pénurie que de répartir le
rap de sucettes
comme le disait je sais plus trop quel
chef d'entreprise en période de
croissance il a pas de mauvais manager
et s'est pas complètement faux
distribuer durable de sucettes à peu
près tout le monde sait faire ça gérer
la con gérer la contrainte croissante
compliqué il ya peu de gens qui savent
bien faire ça donc le donc ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler les low tech
en fait c'est ce et autres contraintes
haute intelligence et tirer le meilleur
parti de ce qui nous reste c'est plutôt
comme ça qu'il faut voir les choses et
nous en france visiblement on a plutôt
nos chances puisque vous dites que la
france est un pays où on est plutôt
brillant quand on devrait innover sous
contrat rui alors on devrait avoir de
chance si c'est ça la voix qu'on nous
indique enfin pour le moment deux pour
sa photo lundi qu'il ferait avant notre
président il va au consumer electronic
show il chausse des lunettes 3d virtuel
je sais pas quoi donc ce n'est pas
vraiment la voie qui nous indique mais
oui si on nous indiquait cette voie je
pense qu'on serait plutôt bon parce
qu'on a un système éducatif en france
qui fait de très bons ingénieurs ont
même très bien tous les autres alors
c'est un sujet qu'on maltraite tous les
autres j'ai pas favorable mais en
attendant on fait des gens et qu'est ce
que ce jour a dit qu'est ce que c'est
que le métier d'ingénieur cti essaie de
tirer le meilleur parti d'un truc contre
un jeu son métier c'est clair
d'optimisation sous contrainte et
globalement la france est plutôt bonne à
ce jeu là les ingénieurs français on
nous les appliquer un peu partout dans
le monde
pour pour faire les succès des autres y
compris les succès pour partie des
gaffes à et le chief technology officer
d'apple longtemps été un franc soeur
donc le donc donc je pense qu'on serait
bon à ce jeu là si on se disait c'est
avec cette règle là qu'on va jouer pour
le moment on a une classe politique qui
n'a pas envie de nous emmener dans ce
sens là alors peut-être que on est trop
peu nombreux à dire comme moi ça serait
intéressant de faire ça pour que la
pression globale qui remonte à ce qu'on
a coutume d'appeler des gouvernants mais
qui sont en fait des arbitres heures
face qu'ils arbitrent dans la bonne
direction
peut-être que l'information commence à
exister de manière suffisante mais sur
particulièrement obtus
j'en sais rien peut-être qu'on a juste
la faute à pas de chance parce qu'on
change pas président toute les semaines
tous les cinq ont encore un grand plan
sur l'ia devrait être en place oui en
effet un grand sens du grand plan sur
l'ir il faut faire le grand plan sur le
climat pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que cette contrainte existe
vraiment alors que l'ia c'est quand même
du gadget je veux dire
faire des robots qui montre les étages
pour vous servir votre boisson parce que
vous n'avez pas envie d'embaucher un
garçon d'hôtel s'est enfin je veux dire
si on n'a que ça à [ __ ] dans la vie
c'est quand même dommage que le de même
que faire un robot qui gardent voiture
au parking quand vous allez prendre
l'avion je vous assure que dans 20 ans
ça sera pas votre premier problème donc
cramer les ressources d'intelligence
qu'on a sur des trucs qui sont juste
s'amuser avec des gadgets dont des
univers de gens qui sont déjà des gens
qui sont du bon côté de la barrière
les gens qui prennent l'avion et qui ont
un problème pour retrouver la voiture
une semaine après c'est pas les plus
pauvres me semble être une très mauvaise
allocation du jus de cerveau qui nous
qui est encore à notre disposition alors
qu'on est dans une course contre la
montre parce que on aurait trois mille
ans devant nous on s'en foutrait gens
communiquent ils nous emmerdent d'abord
on va faire les robots ensuite on se
dire ah bon ça nous fatigue on a plus
envie c'est pas drôle et c'est plutôt
faire autre chose et on a encore tout le
temps devant nous mais là on a plus on
est dans une course contre la montre
on n'a pas le temps on va se retrouver
juste après une séquence alors une
séquence en trois ans 3,11 le premier
run c'est la minute bouclé et chronique
tant attendu le deuxième round c'est
charlie qui vient ici avec son invité
cédric karl mais je vous en dis pas plus
pour la séquence c'est maintenant ça
c'est un prêt et après il y aura le
troisième rang je vais essayer de me
retrouver le troisième rang ce sera la
chronique de la tortue et puis après on
reviendra avec vous jean marc jancovici
[Musique]
ok je vais le dire un truc qui me
redonne foi en l'humanité et je vous en
parle tout de suite
salut à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver dans cette nouvelle minute
bouclé et encore plus aujourd'hui parce
que j'ai une bonne nouvelle à vous
annoncer
la taxe 3 et enfin supprimer non ah non
je sais le glyphosate va être interdite
dans notre pays plutôt prévu non plus
bah non je sais pas alors bon ok je vous
fais pas plus patiente et j'ai lu dans
un article récemment que selon un
rapport que réalise chaque année le site
de revente de vêtements suède ap le
marché de la seconde main devrait
dépasser celui de l'apa spatiale en 2028
et y apprend ça dans les dents prêts
marquent quand on sait ce que
l'industrie du textile engendre comme
problème ou ses biens environnementaux
sociaux sociétaux
bah ça fait quand même plaisir à lire
quelques chiffres pour se rappeler ce
qu'il en est actuellement l'industrie du
textile c'est la deuxième industrie la
plus polluante du monde 66 % des
ouvriers sont des femmes et des enfants
1100 personnes sont décédées lors de
l'effondrement durana plaza un bâtiment
de dhaka au bangladesh qui abritait des
sous traitants de marques occidentales
voilà pour tableau pas très glorieux du
coup que nous dit le rapport qui me fait
croire que nous sommes à l'aube d'un
changement positif et bien le marché de
la seconde main atteint aujourd'hui 25
milliards de dollars avec une
prospective de doubler la mise d'ici
cinq ans selon une étude 64% des femmes
achèterez en seconde main vous serez
motivé à le faire se plaquent chaîne
data automatisation des stocks
applications de vente et d'achat de
seconde main qui foisonnent et qui ne
désemplissent pas en termes de visiteurs
bref de l'armoire que l'on trie au
nouveau propriétaire le flux de
marchandises et facilité aujourd'hui par
les innovations technologiques dans dix
ans quand le marché de la fast fashion
avoisinera les 44 milliards de dollars
celui de la friperie dépassera selon les
perspectives les 60 milliards de dollars
enfin le rapport nous indique que si
tout le monde achète ne serait-ce qu'un
objets d'occasion au lieu de neuf là
cette année en 2019
eh bien on pourrait économiser 2,5
millions de tonnes d'émissions de co2
qui équivaut à 500 mille voitures qui
prennent la route pendant un an
11 milliards de kilowattheures qui
équivaut à l'éclairage de la tour eiffel
pendant cent quarante et un ans 94
milliards de
litres d'eau avec lesquels on pourrait
remplir plus de 1000 fontaine bellagio
ou encore plus de 200 3000 tonnes de
déchets du côté des consommateurs et
bien la prise de conscience autour des
enjeux éthiques de la production de
vêtements bas fait son chemin depuis des
années je vous avais parlé d'ailleurs il
ya quelques temps dans une précédente
vidéo que la consommation de textile en
france avait récemment bc bat comme quoi
ça se vérifie et du coup bah c'est trop
cool
à titre personnel je me balade dans les
friperies plusieurs fois par mois dans
lesquels je trouve souvent des perles et
des raretés encore en état limite avant
d'aller m'acheter un nouveau manteau
pour l'hiver gros pulls ou des bottes
ben je vais dans les friperies qui
regorge souvent de trésors originaux de
qualité et qui diffère avec la mode
masculine du moment se démarquer de
façon éthique et responsable
je crois que c'est mon credo quoi par
exemple avec ce petit chemisier
ballantyne haut que je porte
il doit bien dater des années 80-90 je
le trouvais dans une petite boutique de
dépôt vente à madrid et je laime d'amour
donc je vous invite vous aussi aller
chiner dans les friperies
vous allez voir vous n'allez pas être
déçus à bientôt salut
[Musique]
et merci je rappelle juste que la grande
boucle et parle de madrid dans sa
chronique mais la grande boucle et vit à
madrid
tout est normal tout étant mal se réfère
charlie bonsoir c'est la séquence est
maintenant c'est à séquence présente
autant d'invités bonsoir alors
existe-t-il des innovations dans le
domaine de l'énergie que nous aurions
oublié
peut-on apprendre et transmettre sur la
question de l'énergie
peut-on s'amuser avec les énergies
renouvelables on va tenter de répondre à
toutes ces questions avec notre invité
ce soir donc cédric karl bonsoir cédric
bonsoir bonsoir cédric vous êtes
directeur de l'atelier 21
si on fait un petit retour flash back
dans le passé vous vous destiniez à des
études d'ingénieur vous êtes orienté
vers vers le design et vous avez eu un
intérêt assez rapide pour l'énergie
pourquoi parce que en tant que designer
en fait on en étant intéressé par
affectées par ces questions d'éco
conception et de l'impact de nos modes
de vie donc à la fin des années 90 je me
suis aperçu qu'effectivement on avait la
moitié de nos impacts annuels étaient
des impacts liés à notre consommation
donc c'est pas seulement le pétrole
qu'on met dans l'avion dans la voiture
le gaz pour chauffer la maison et
l'électricité pour utiliser nos
appareils électriques
ça c'est la moitié de nos impacts
climatiques l'autre moitié c'est l'eau
qu'il ya dans ce vers le livre ici qui a
été fabriqué en france
les appareils qu'on consomme
il qu'on remplace un peu trop souvent
les vêtements etc
et ça c'est ce qu'on appelle l'énergie
la consommation c'est l'énergie grise
alors c'est un truc est pas trés
populariser et pas très vulgariser mais
c'est un au cheval de bataille c'est
c'est à dire que vous êtes obligé de
considérer dans vos calculs si vous
dites ça c'est une solution pour demain
pour économiser le climat vous ne pouvez
pas mettre sur le marché des voitures
qui serait économes en énergie si pour
les construire vous utilisiez des années
et des années de pétrole donc voilà
c'est d'énergie grise et ça rentre dans
les calculs pour faire des choix de
technologies pour faire des choix de
consommation et pour faire des choix
industriels aussi alors vous êtes
directeur de l'atelier 21 l'atelier 21
si j'ai bien compris c'est une sorte de
boîte à outils sur le cette question
fait de l'énergie dans lequel il y a
comme toute boîte à outils beaucoup
d'outils il n'ya pas les eaux
énergétique et le solar system il ya
radio 3 s il ya le dessus synergie barre
il ya un lieu station et il ya le projet
aussi vejen box alors peut-être pas
pouvoir tous les sites et l'a peut-être
qu'on peut commencer par un projet c'est
paléo énergétiques alors c'était un
projet de recherche
je crois participatif dans le domaine de
l'énergie pour une fois c'est une façon
je crois de redécouvrir des inventions
du passé qui ont peut-être été mise de
côté et qu'il est peut-être utile de
redécouvrir en ayant travaillé entre la
france et la suisse avec des gens qui
essaie d'innover dans le domaine
énergétique en tant que designer donc on
a travaillé souvent avec des ingénieurs
des sociologues des physiciens etc et on
s'était aperçu qui nous manquait en fait
une ressource qui était qui était
extrêmement dissipée dans plein de deux
canaux les archives l'internet les vieux
magazines en fait il ya beaucoup de
choses en fait qui ont été inventés lors
des différentes crises que le xxème
siècle a vécu
du pétrole les guerres etc dans lesquels
en fait on était en tout simplement en
pénurie en fait de matériaux et de
ressources et et dans ces périodes là en
fait il ya une innovation qui est
galopante on va utiliser d'autres
ressources on va utiliser l'énergie
solaire on va on va créer des si je vous
ai ramené une archive originale d'un
journal qui s'appelle le monde illustré
que beaucoup de gens connaissent et en
fait c'est une imprimante solaire donc
c'est un concentrateur solaire qui a été
mis au point par monsieur mouche au qui
à l'époque un enseignant en
mathématiques qui qui à l'époque dit le
charbon n'existe pas en quantités
limitées il faut il faut l'économiser
je pense qu'il se rend compte aussi
d'impact du charbon dans les villes à
l'époque au niveau de la santé et il dit
voilà il faut utiliser l'énergie solaire
et donc il va créer des concentrateurs
solaires donc à l'époque qui vont qui
vont eux marché avec la vapeur et il va
faire tourner des machines industrielles
quelques années après ça inspire a
notamment une une invention d'un
américain qui fera une installation pour
pomper l'eau du nil mais voilà en fait
la moue chaud et est un est un grand
inventeur de son époque et des comme ça
il y en a il y en a plein le livre est à
la base c'est un site internet
alors lorsque l'idée c'est de mettre
cette ressource à disposition d'aidés
mais coeur des gens qui font la
transition énergétique des jeunes de
maintenant et des ingénieurs pour
comprendre et prendre de la hauteur un
peu sur qu'est-ce qu'une innovation
aujourd'hui comprendre pourquoi des
choses dont on fonctionnait pas parce
que c'est aussi ça qu'on recherche avec
le projet paléo énergétique c'est
comprendre pourquoi une un moment donné
ça fonctionne
un autre moment donné ça ne fonctionne
pas et selon nous voilà le prix aussi du
baril de pétrole a fait le yo yo et a
rendu un coup les énergies renouvelable
rentables
un coup pas du tout et puis on n'avait
pas cette urgence climatique en fait qu'
aujourd'hui
donc voila quand vous invente y ait une
imprimante qui marchent à l'énergie
solaire en 1880 on disait c'est bien
gentil mon petit bonhomme mais où est
l'urgence donc il avait beau dire oui à
bientôt il y aura plus de charbon
voilà ils n'étaient pas forcément écouté
et puis passer comme ça pour plein
d'invention à base d'hydrogène de
véhicules électriques de choses qui sont
qui était en avance sur leur temps
finalement on va beaucoup d'inventions
sont listées dans cet ouvrage réseau
futur que vous avez co dirigé et quelle
est celle qui vous a le plus marqué ou
celle qui aurait le plus de sens à
mettre en perspective avec avec au genre
d'image
alors on va partir sur un truc qui fait
partie de la production du bouquin est
en fait dans les années dans les années
fin de la guerre on a deux bricoleurs à
angers qui vont faire rouler un camion à
l'hydrogène et cet hydrogène il a
fabriqué avec un moulin à eau puisqu'il
utilise la force de l'eau pour faire
fonctionner des des alternateurs dont il
est dynamique qui produisent
l'électricité avec cette d'électricité
vont faire des électrolyses pour stocker
l'hydrogène et pour faire rouler un
camion et quelques années plus tard on
va voir dans cette filiation
d'inventeurs jean-luc perrier donc c'est
pas très dur à retenir c'est un monsieur
qui fait des bulles qui lui est prof de
physique et les mêmes physicien à
l'université catholique d'angers et lui
il va faire rouler à l'époque une simca
avec de l'hydrogène aussi sauf que
l'hydrogène il la fabrique avec un
concentrateur solaire comme comme
mouchot en fait et on est toujours dans
du côté de la loire etc
et puis il ya un autre exemple sur les
concentrateurs solaires c'est que
léonard de vinci voulait faire fondre du
bronze à l'énergie solaire
le bronze a été réquisitionnée
malheureusement impossible à cause de la
guerre à l'époque on pense que s'il
avait fait ça à l'époque d'énergie
solaire en tout cas ce serait aurait pu
pour potentiellement s'imposer pendant
des centaines d'années et vivre une
autre vie que ce qu'elle le connaît
aujourd'hui
et d'ailleurs en fait à la station eux
on est en train de créer un prototype de
forge solaire donc on va tester ça à
partir du 10 mai et ça va être comme ça
tout l'été avec une tout simplement une
lentille de fresnel on va concentrer les
rayons bien faire fondre des métaux on
va essayer de voir ce qu'on peut faire
avec ça très bientôt que dans l'atelier
d'un terrain qu'il ya cette dimension un
peu historique et actuelle avec paléo
énergétique et donc rétro futur il ya
station eux qui était un lieu à
montreuil qui permet de découvrir un
petit peu sont ceux dont on vient de
parler et j'aurais voulu en fait que
vous nous parliez aussi d'autres choses
c'est le projet régen boxe
alors je sais pas si c'est du low tech
ou pas et j'ai le bac c'est sûr que
c'est l'idée c'est régine boxe il est
aussi dans notre bouquin il est là tout
à la fin régine boxe en fait c'est un
projet qui est né de deux d'une
invention qui existe déjà
donc nous on n'a rien inventé c'est
c'est juste un électro chimistes des
années 60-70 extrêmement connue qui
s'appelle karl cordesse notamment à
travailler sur les piles à combustible à
l'époque qui donneront celles qui seront
dans les missions apollo donc c'est
quelqu'un absolument reconnu et à
l'époque il travaille sur les piles en
général ils travaillent aussi sur les
piles alcalines et lui va sortir à
l'époque des piles alcalines et un
chargeur de piles alcalines donc les
piles alcalines
vous savez elle ne se rechargent pas on
les appelle en anglais les single use
batterie et du coup on s'est dit on a
regardé la littérature scientifique ça
paraissait très sérieux on a on a acheté
un objet qui est sorti à l'époque le
régénérateur rayo vague qui était mis
sur le marché pendant juste un an ou
deux donc il est à la station il expose
aussi en présente ça comme une pièce à
conviction
et puis là nous en fait on a refait en
fait on a repris le brevet en fait qui
est dans le domaine public tout
simplement et c'est ce qu'on dit c'est
que tout ça c'est bourré de domaine
public donc c'est mondialement
mobilisables c'est le quadrige inbox
dans le partage c'est un brevet qu'on a
repris et qu'on reparte âge voilà tout
en fait il ya un kit s'en fait et on
peut construire montesson si vous voulez
ça paraît tellement fou de recharger des
piles alcalines que nous aussi disent
qu'il faut qu'on fasse avancer un
programme de recherche donc ce qu'on a
fait c'est que on a dit voilà c'est un
programme de recherche n'est pas un
produit qu'on met sur le marché du tout
est ce qu on a rajouté nous comme
briques technologiques dans la région
boxe c'est un système qui permet déjà de
décharger les piles automatiquement et
de les recharger et d'enregistrer tout
ça sur un ordinateur ça vous fait ce
qu'on appelle des courbes de charges ça
ou dessine à quelle vitesse se décharge
de la pila quelle vitesse elle se
recharge et pour nous c'est essentiel de
démontrer la véracité ou pas de ce truc
que nous ne nous mêmes on savait pas si
c'était vrai ça nous semblait tout à
fait plausible parce que un produit est
sorti
c'est karl cordage qui daf à l'époque
qu'il à prototyper et qu'il a mis sur le
marché et qu'il a breveté et ce truc
disparaît à l'époque pas forcément parce
que les industriels se retire parce que
ils sont méchants et voilà c'est
peut-être parce que c'est un flop
commercial
c'est peut-être parce qu'à l'époque dans
les années 80 on se dit pas forcément
qu'on va recharger des piles et que
peut-être il est beaucoup trop cher
aussi peut-être à l'époque c'est les
fabricants depuis itunes qui vont pas
être très content d'eux si si si si
certains se réjouissent nous envoie des
petits cadeaux on est en train de faire
un benchmark aussi puisque comment les
décharges
on sait exactement ce qu'il ya dans une
pile alcaline donc on peut comparer les
piles alcalines
il faut savoir qu'il ya aucune
obligation pour les constructeurs
d'indiquer les militants perreur que
vous trouvez dans la capacité de la pile
et donc nous ce qu'on dit et on dit l'un
d'eux on est pour la création d'un
observatoire national du stockage
pourquoi parce qu'on stocke avec des
éléments électro chimique mais aussi des
éléments cinétique ont fait des stocks
des fois dans des volumes d'eau et voilà
et en fait tout ça faut de l'observer il
faut le partager en tout cas
l'observateur national du stockage pour
nous c'est tout ce qui est batteries de
stockage batteries de voitures batteries
de téléphones batteries qui sont mis sur
le marché pour recharger les appareils
ou les batteries alcalines et donc
l'idée c'est de partager du data sur les
batteries pour savoir ce qui est
vraiment dedans et puis bah que les
meilleurs gagnent quoi tout simplement
et puis qu'on arrête d'acheter sans
savoir ce qu'il ya dedans on retrouve un
fils un fil conducteur en fait dans les
différents projets ou dans les
différents outils de la boîte à outils
atelier 21 c'est l'idée de vulgariser et
puis de partager un certain nombre de
connaissances et puis vous êtes allé
plus loin ou autrement avec des ateliers
sur la précarité énergétique ça je crois
que vous êtes parti en fait d'un constat
sur la précarité énergétique notamment
des étudiants
et voilà quel est le constat est où est
ce que ça vous a emmené en fait j'ai
participé à pas mal de jeux de workshops
d'études etc sur la précarité
énergétique est en fait un moment donné
on a on a réalisé qu'il y avait
je crois quasiment un demi million
d'étudiants en france qui sont victimes
de précarité énergétique et donc qu'ils
ont du mal à se chauffer ou en tout cas
qu'ils ont sur leur budget mensuel une
charge de plus de 10% à louer à
l'énergie ce qui fait qu'ils font pas
d'autre chose avec et on s'est dit
puisque nous on travaille beaucoup avec
les écoles ce qu'on fait c'est beaucoup
des choses pédagogique on bosse en bosse
y compris avec des grandes écoles qui
nous invite avec leurs grands élèves et
des entreprises aussi des fois pour
réfléchir à l'innovation est ce que c
est comme on interagit avec beaucoup
avec les avec thé avec des écoles on
s'est dit qu'on allait mettre au point
un workshop open source et itinérants à
destination des écoles et que c'était
les étudiants qui allait réfléchir à
comment lutter contre la précarité
énergétique chez les autres étudiants
donc voilà c'est un projet où on est ses
pairs et du coup on découvre aussi ce
que c'est la précarité énergétique en
france parce que c'est un phénomène qui
touche un foyer sur cinq est bientôt
deux foyers sur cinq c'est quand même
assez alarmiste et et là du coup les
étudiants peuvent aussi s'armer et
trouver des solutions pour aussi des
foyers et pas que les étudiants autour
de l'énergie au c on peut aussi s'amuser
on peut aussi entend faire la fête et
c'est la musique dépenser de l'énergie
dépensée l'énergie humaine alors c'est
tout le monde n'aura pas compris mais
vous vous ai compris ma position
enfin c'est pour parler de cela cinq
systèmes
donc c'est un projet je vois voulez vous
l'art borgel harbour et au nom de toute
la communauté qu'il ya derrière parce
que parce que ce soit rétro future
station solar system c'est des
communautés qu'il ya derrière
à chaque fois oui cela ressentent
système on est à hong kong on est à
berlin on est tel aviv on est au pays
basque on est à marseille
et puis on a des demandes dans le monde
entier donc bientôt on sera on sera
partout voilà c'est c'est un des projets
qu'on a monté pour que pour qu'on puisse
parler d'énergie dans le domaine dans la
sphère publique et donc ses descentes
système qui sont autonomes en énergie
qui fonctionne avec l'énergie solaire et
l'énergie du public puisqu'on fait
pédaler les gens sur des vélos pour
alimenter le dj et la fête
ça fonctionne les gens pédales les gens
aiment pédaler les gens aiment bien
toucher du doigt un peu tout ça et ça
permet d'être un point de départ aussi
pour parler tout ça et de pour une fois
avec des sujets aussi lourd que le
climat l'urgence climatique les guerres
liées à l'énergie se décontracter un bon
coup et rigoler ensemble pour encore
plus en forme demain dans le sable
système d'aqueduc ouvre la cdc de des
platines le dj il est il a sa propre
énergie ou à lui indépendant des
machines des enceintes souvent panneaux
solaires et puis des vélos qui sont
connectés au site voila c'est dingue à
petit suffisamment d'énergie pour
pouvoir continuer sans lui il faut faire
des sound systems au milieu des plages
etc
ces voix là c'est aussi une tendance que
moi j'ai vécu c'est tout ce monde de la
musique électronique qui d'un seul coup
sort des clubs sort des boîtes de nuit
et sort des trucs et va organiser ses
propres fait avec ses propres artistes
dans des lieux uniques éphémère ce qu'il
fait là aussi la qualité de ce moment là
c'est qu'il est éphémère et qu'on sait
qu'on le retrouvera pas et alors qu'elle
serait là l'actualité que voudriez
partagés en ce moment parmi tous ces
projets que kate qu'on n'a pas qu'on l'a
pas cité
l'actualité c'est que la station est
tous assez visitable donc on fait aussi
des visites pour les écoles ont fait des
visites pour les animateurs de maisons
de quartier ont fait des visites pour
les entreprises et voilà ces stations
eux donc métro robespierre 236 rue de
paris et on est ouvert du vendredi
samedi dimanche et ont fait la fête on
fait des expos on invite des
associations à présenter leurs travaux
on brasse l'énergie merci beaucoup
cédric plein de bonnes choses pour la
suite c'est à une prochaine
à bientôt merci cédric merci charlie on
passe à la chronique de la tortue avant
de retrouver jean marc jancovici est
laconique de la tortue vous savez celle
qui a plus d'énergie à la fin que le
lièvre a tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir je suis blogueuse et à ce titre
je reçois beaucoup de questions de
lecteurs qui me demandent comment
s'engager efficacement dans la lutte
contre le changement climatique pour la
préservation de la biodiversité et plus
généralement pour un monde socialement
et écologiquement plus juste j'ai moi
même cherché longtemps la réponse à
cette question comme beaucoup d'entre
nous je n'en peux plus d'attendre un
changement qui ne vient pas d'en haut
mais qui a aussi beaucoup de mal à être
impulsée par le bas comme beaucoup je
suis parfois submergés par l'écho
anxiété ce mal qui touche les plus
sensibilisés d'entre nous désespérer de
voir un jour un changement radical
opérer je suis fatigué de ces petits
gestes qui ne me satisfont plus recyclé
acheter en vrac
acheter bio local de saison et c'est
dans notre côté je ne sais pas ou à
louer mon énergie
en creux il ya toujours cette obsédante
question quelles actions servirait
vraiment à quelque chose trois
réflexions importantes à ce sujet
premièrement ce n'est pas parce que je
ne peux pas tout solutionner seul que ce
que je fais ne sert à rien consomme 7
milliards d'individus sur terre
il faut abandonner le fantasme de sauver
le monde à moi seul et croire à la
puissance du collectif deuxièmement il
faut aussi arrêter de penser que nous
avons tous besoin d'être d'accord pour
que le changement n'advienne les
changements ont toujours été impulsée
par les minorités la majorité se
contentent d'emboîter le pas nous
n'avons donc pas besoin que tout le
monde soit écolo pour bâtir un avenir
plus durable et enfin troisièmement il
n'y a pas de formes d'engagement mieux
qu'une j'ai eu l'occasion cette semaine
d'entendre parler d'eux et lui qui
tenait à peu près le même discours sans
les entreprises sans les associations
sans les citoyens
un élu n'a pas de poids c'est une chaîne
une chaîne où chacun joue son rôle
nous avons certes besoin de personnes
engagées politiquement à tous les
échelons mais nous avons aussi besoin
d'entrepreneurs éthiques
nous avons besoin d'associations de
protection de l'environnement de
désobéissance civile etc
nous avons besoin de citoyens qui
pensent qu'ils boycottent qui interpelle
qui marche
nous avons besoin de médias qui place
ces problématiques au coeur du
traitement de l'information nous avons
besoin d'experts d'intellectuels de
scientifiques qui se penchent sur ces
questions
nous avons certainement besoin d'autre
chose que je n'ai pas pensé à lister
brève dans la construction d'un avenir
plus radieux chacun a un rôle à jouer le
rôle qui lui convient alors tout le
monde sur le pont
[Musique]
de retour sur le plateau et rendez vous
du futur et le jean marc jancovici
le citoyen doit faire sa part l'expert
doit faire sa part comme le disait
anaëlle dans la chronique de la tortue
le politique fort bref c'est une vision
un petit peu idyllique
chacun peut faire quand même un petit
peu sa part de changement non c'est une
vision réaliste parce que de toute façon
elle a raison personne ne porte le monde
sur ses épaules et même les gens qui
dans des périodes où les systèmes
étaient un peu dirigiste ou dont on
pensait qu'ils portaient le monde sur
leurs épaules enfin je veux dire le roi
de france c'est pas la france
donc il a quand même besoin du reste de
la france pour que la france soit ce
qu'elle est donc oui chacun fait sa part
pourtant là on doit tous se rendre
compte que on doit sortir tout doucement
du dogme du progrès le fameux depuis 11
ans doit pas sortir du top du progrès on
doit sortir du dogme qui est sans qu'on
ait besoin de rien faire de spécial
demain sera mieux qu'aujourd'hui cette
fois dont on a besoin de sortir dogmes
et du progrès non parce que encore une
fois ça dépend c'est ce que j'ai tout à
l'heure ça dépend de la de votre vision
si vous considérez que avoir quelque
chose qui dure plus longtemps
c'est un progrès à ce moment il faut le
faire et c'est un progrès pardon de ce
truisme
donc ça dépend de ce qu'on qualifie être
un progrès pendant il faut bien voir que
là on sort d'un monde en expansion ça
fait dix mille ans que le monde est en
expansion c'est à dire que comme les ans
comme les hommes se sédentarisent ya dix
ans on est quelques millions sur terre
sauf accident transitoire la population
n'a pas arrêté d'augmenter les accidents
transitoire ils ont peut être un peu
saignant quand même à tous les sens du
terme
quelques épidémie d épidémie qu'on fait
les sacré ménage
il ya eu des guerres qu'on fait un peu
le ménage moins que les épidémies il ya
eu des famines qu'on fait le ménage
moins que les épidémies mais globalement
on est en expansion on est en expansion
sur les territoires occupés on était une
expansion sur le nombre d'objets qu'on
sait fabriquer on est fâcheux dire on
est en expansion surtout donc on a un
logigramme qui est bien adaptée ou fait
d'être dans un univers en expansion et
soit dit en passant dans un univers en
expansion c'est des premiers sont
simples à gérer parce que vous pouvez
toujours ajouter des moyens pour gérer
un problème nouveau aux moyens que vous
aviez pour gérer le problème ancien dont
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous et faire
pas le problème les moyens
dans un univers qui est plus en
expansion ça devient considérablement
plus compliqué parce que vous réglez a
ou b mais pas les deux en même temps
donc il faut faire des choix ce qui est
compliqué il faut il faut les faire
partager
ce qui est compliqué donc c'est clair
qu'on on est dans une pays de meaux mais
il ya quelque part quelque chose qui
ressemble à une nouvelle idée du progrès
faut pas mettre le progrès là où elle
mettait avant on a beaucoup mis quand
même jusqu'à maintenant le progrès dans
l'objet
ça c'est clair qu'on va buter sur des
limites de ce point de vue je vous cite
une société - fossiles n'a pas
d'alternative à la décroissance
les jeunes qui manifestent pour le
climat se rendent pas compte qu'il va
être impossible de garder niveau de vie
actuel le niveau de vie qu'ils ont
actuellement
vous pensez vraiment que ceux qui sont
dans la rue tous les jeunes qui
manifestent en ce moment pour le climat
sauvez le climat bon climat sauver la
nature sauvage vivant se rendent pas
compte que oui là ils doivent emprunter
un autre chemin qui sera plus de la
décroissance comme diraient certains
je pense que ils s'en rendent pas
nécessairement compte
et quand il s'en rendre compte ils
n'arrivent pas nécessairement à le faire
je connais un certain nombre de cas de
figure dans lequel des gens qui se
rendent compte que c'est globalement ça
qu'il faut suivre comme trajectoires
sont très à l'aise avec l'idée que leur
propre consommation doit augmenter
il arrive le paradoxe que leurs propres
revenus doit augmenter qu'ils doivent
être capable d'habiter un logement plus
grand
et caetera et qu'il n'y a pas de raison
qu'ils renoncent à leur voyage en avion
donc ces séries sont pas tous comme ça
on est bien d'accord mais y en a une
fraction qui sont comme ça et le grand
paradoxe en fait c'est que les gens qui
sont entre guillemets les plus éclairés
appartiennent souvent à des classes
sociales qui sont plus favorisés que la
moyenne
et là il ya une loi du genre qui est
plus vous gagnez d'argent
votre empreinte carbone est élevé en
première approximation parce que si vous
ne dépensez pas ici vous allez le
dépenser là bas et si vous ne dépensez
pas avec vous l'épargné vous allez
financer des activités qui vont émettre
donc dans tous les cas de figure il ya
malheureusement une loi du genre qui est
plus vous avez d'argent plus votre
empreinte carbone et élever encore une
fois c'est il ya des variations mais
c'est très compliqué de s'en abstraire
en tout cas donc cesser c'est toute la
difficulté alors après on tombe aussi
sur pourquoi moi je devrais commencer à
prier alors que la société s'est pas
mise en mouvement donc je dis pas que
leur militantisme et inutile je dis
qu'il est pas suffisant malheureusement
dans un certain nombre de cas de figure
et j'ai pu observer pour s'abstraire
totalement des contradictions que je
viens d'évoquer
il faut qu'il soit relié peut-être
davantage par le politique mais il
semble qu'ils puissent un quart des
alors il ya des gens chez qui ils
s'incarnent tout à fait je connais des
gens qui ont volontairement baissé leur
niveau de vie là pour le coup
en choisissant une autre orientation
professionnelle l'habitait à un autre
endroit etc
sans ça se voit aussi mais il n'a pas la
majeure partie des gens qui défilent
pour le climat c'est des gens qui sont
restés dans leur vie existantes et qui
viennent vont juste te dire ça serait
quand même bien de s'occuper du problème
des gens qui bascule totalement
d'abord ils sont pas nécessairement il
une partie d'entre eux sont retournés
entre guillemets l'agriculture donc ils
viennent pas en ville pour manifester
ils sont là où ils sont il y en a une
partie qui sont d'ordre et dans des
modes
j'ai envie d'y rap contestataire
vis-à-vis de la société dans son
ensemble est une manifestation s'est
même déjà quelque chose de trop inscrits
dans le moule pour qu'ils aient envie de
s'y mettre
voilà donc vous avez de tout à la fois
des gens qui sont qui vont jusqu'au bout
de la démarche et qui se met en
cohérence avec ce qu'ils pensent mais
pour ce que j'en observe c'est plutôt
une minorité dans l'ensemble des gens
qui disent il faut faire quelque chose
ça veut dire que le réveil va être
forcément très dur c'est à dire qu'on va
devoir prendre conscience qu'il n'y a
plus de croissance qu'elle sera
certainement l'un vertes car y'en a déjà
joué une bonne nouvelle pour vous en
europe y en a déjà plus depuis 10 ans
quand vous regardez les indicateurs
physiques qui sont par exemple la
production industrielle qui sont par
exemple le nombre de mètres carrés
construits chaque année qui sont par
exemple la quantité de camions qui
transportent des marchandises
vous êtes aujourd'hui en europe
légèrement en dessous du niveau de 2007
donc la croissance s'est arrêtée en
europe en 2007 et mon pari c'est que si
ça me dépasse 2007 ça va pas le faire
longtemps donc alors simplement une
partie des élites urbaines s'en rendent
pas compte parce que dans la répartition
de ce qui reste
elles sont du bon côté de la barrière
donc elle sait les empêche pas de vivre
voir ça les empêche pâti de mieux en
mieux les ceux qui en souffrent le plus
sont des gens qui sont aux marges aux
franges dont notamment les gilets jaunes
mais pas que et c'est des gens qui vont
se réveiller
à un moment on les aura pas vu venir
globalement donc le mais aujourd'hui ça
c'est déjà le cas
insisté aujourd'hui c'est déjà en marche
une question d'aurélie piette
l'économiste aurélie piette et qu'on va
recevoir bientôt dans un rendez-vous le
futur je n'en parlerai plus tard un
petit peu spécial qui sera à bordeaux où
est-ce qu'on en est de la mise en place
de l'idée de décentralisation
énergétique
alors là j'imagine qu'elle le fait
référence au projet je ne sais pas ce
que c'est par exalead
oui je ne sais pas ce que c'est une
énergie qui était parfaitement
décentralisée qui a longtemps été
l'énergie des hommes c'est le bois c'est
très décentralisé le bois une énergie
qui a été raisonnablement décentraliser
ses les chutes d'eau ce que vous les
utiliser là où elles sont nées par
ailleurs au moment où on avait des
moulins à eau
donc qu'est ce que c'est qu'une énergie
décentralisée si on parle des éoliennes
et des panneaux solaires
c'est un très bon moyen de multiplier
par 10 à 40
la quantité de capitaux qu'il faut
mettre dans le système électrique alors
je vais vous donner deux ou trois
exemples aujourd'hui si vous mettez
boutabout toutes les puissances
souscrites par les consommateurs
d'électricité
vous vous avez un abonnement électrique
votre abonnement électrique il est
probablement deux ou six ou neuf
kilovoltampères pas ce qu'on appelle des
caves et à des kilowatts
accor tient qu en gros vous pouvez
simultanément brancher des appareils qui
soutient de l'électricité jusqu'à
hauteur de 9 km vous avez 30 millions de
foyers en france 30 x 9
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que ça fait
27 donc vous avez 270 gigawatts
d'abonnement électrique en france
plus vous rajoutez les industriels pour
vous situer aux alentours de 400 il sauf
que la puissance installée en france
c'est 100 gigawatts quatre fois moins
pourquoi parce que en ce moment vous
êtes ici vous n'êtes pas chez vous donc
pendant que l'endroit où vous travaillez
appel de l'électricité l'endroit où vous
résister ne rappelle pas puis vous avez
peut-être si vous êtes assez ri je suis
un résident secondaire et à saint-louis
dit oui parce que j'en avais une non et
je dis oui parce que je comprends vous
connaissez le concept de résidences
secondaires
vous en avez entendu parler alors sauf à
ce que vous ayez le don d'ubiquité ou
vos enfants et des parasites
a priori quand vous êtes chez vous
n'êtes pas dans les résidences
secondaires et inversement
à ce moment on apele l'électricité chez
vous on l'appelle pas dans la résidence
donc en fait par un effet de lissage
vous avez la possibilité de d'installer
beaucoup moins de puissance en
production que la totalité des
possibilités techniques d'appel de
puissance du côté des consommateurs
simard un chacun à son panneaux solaires
sur son toit vous allez dimensionné la
puissance produite au maximum de la
puissance appelée installation par
installation
donc ça veut dire qu'au lieu d'avoir 100
gigawatts de puissance sur le sol
rien qu'à cause de ça vous en avez 400
en plus le solaire il produit pas tout
le temps et produit 15 % du temps alors
que les installations classiques
centralisée que ce soit du charbon du
gaz du nucléaire ça se balade entre 50
et 80 dont vous avez besoin encore une
fois 2 x 3 puis vous avez besoin de
stocker que ce soit du vent ou du soleil
à ce moment faut encore multiplier par
deux parce que vous avez des pertes au
stockage donc il faut produire
l'électricité qui sera perdue donc en
gros si vous êtes dans le rêve rifkin
liens de chacun vit heureux chez soi
avec son panneaux solaires sur son toit
ils ont et ses veaux x n'importe quoi
entre 10 et 20 la puissance installée et
vous multipliez les capitaux nécessaires
par 40 à 50
c'est de l'argent qu'on n'a pas donc la
décentralisation électrique
non seulement ce n'est pas une bonne
idée mais si on a envie de perdre son
temps et son argent c'est la meilleure
idée qu'on aime parce que l'électricité
ne se stocke pas assez à cause de cette
réalité physique et que par ailleurs
vont mutualiser les us vont mutualiser
la la la la la puissance installée en
production quand tout le monde par la
loi des grands nombres
quant au monde est branché sur le même
réseau et c'est la raison pour laquelle
historiquement on a fait des réseaux
c'est pas parce que nos ancêtres étaient
des crétins c'est parce que c'était un
moyen d'économiser la construction de
centrales
il ya des énergies pour lesquels au
contraire la décentralisation c'est la
voix de la raison
vous n'avez aucune raison de faire
fonctionner un poêle à bois français
avec du bois importé du brésil
donc quand on parle de descendre et vous
n'avez aucune raison de faire
fonctionner une pompe à chaleur
installée dans le berry avec des
calories venant du sol alsacien d'accord
aucun sens
donc vous avez des installations pour
lesquelles c'est pertinent de raisonner
locale et vous avez des installations
pour lesquelles c'est pas pertinent de
raisonner locale au contraire c'est la
mutualisation qui vous offrent la
meilleure économie d'échelle et pour
regarder ces trucs là il faut le
regarder de manière pragmatique il faut
il faut pas se dire a priori il ya deux
vérités que dans le local où a priori il
ya deux vérités que dans le centralisée
en fait dans une course contre la montre
il n'ya de vérité que dans ce qui va
vous permettre d'agir le plus vite
c'est là c'est là la vérité et quand
vous avez besoin de dix fois plus de
capitaux pour régler le même problème
c'est pas agir plus vite
c'est agir comme une tortue mais pas
comme celle qui nous a parlé avec
l'assurance de père marin
une dernière question toute dernière
question là on se dirige vraiment vers
la fin une question de marianne mario
qui est notre psychologue à titre elle
nous rend souvent service était sûr que
nous envoyons en vidéo je regarde par là
parce que c'est jonathan régie qui va le
qui va lancer sa dans un monde contraint
de restriction une d'effondrement à
titre personnel qu'est ce qui reste
ou restera le plus difficile à des
apprend aux caisses qui serait ou sera
le plus difficile de se déprendre
c'est la question marianne la ré
apprendre une forme de fatalisme
j'ai envie de dire au moment où les
monde était très contraint donc je me
permettra le psychologue de faire une
réponse psychologique au moment où le
monde était très contraint le monde
était aussi très stable et les gens
étaient très fataliste
du reste au top ville explique très bien
et dit que dans le monde aristocratique
qui soit dit en passant est à mon avis
quelque chose qui est très adapté au
bond 2 contre 1 vous étiez ce que vous
étiez au courant de votre naissance puis
ça bougeait pas derrière on gagnait ce
qu'on gagnait au moment où ont démarré
son métier et puis ça bougeait pas
derrière et on supporter tout ça parce
qu'on était fataliste parce que le
système vous pousser à être fataliste et
vous disait pas c'est ça ma condition et
puis il ya pas de raison que ça change
et c'est dans le monde démocratique
on a créé un monde d'insatisfaits
perpétuel et on la crée tocqueville il
expliqué très bien aussi il disait en
fait comme on est tous égaux sur la
ligne de départ c'est ça la règle du jeu
si on n'est pas tous égaux sur la ligne
d'arrivée vous aurez toujours quelqu'un
qui a plus que vous dont vous avez
légitimement envie de vous plaindre
d'accord donc il se trouve que quand
vous regardez matériellement comment on
vit aujourd'hui en occident le smicard
français vit comme un nabab
mais comme il existe bernard arnault et
d'autre et consorts il dit c'est pas
juste
voilà donc il se rend pas compte qu'il
vit comme un nabab parce que il y a des
gens qui vivent comme 3 nabab ou
dissoutes en jeu et bien le la
démocratie fait de nous les gens
insatisfaits et la question c'est
comment est ce qu'on apprend dans un
monde contre 1 entre guillemets à se
contenter de ce qu'on a entre guillemets
à être content en se disant pas que
demain on aura plus parce que c'est pas
ça qui se passe ben voilà c'est ça c'est
ça à mon avis c'est ça le plus difficile
c'est comment est ce qu'on arrive à
marier l'espoir et l'envié du lendemain
avec le fait qu'il ya des domaines dans
lequel demain ça sera pas mieux
qu'aujourd'hui il faut sortir de ce
dogme là qu'il faut il faut voir il faut
arriver
voilà je pense que ça fait partie des
choses qui seront
difficile ça veut pas dire que le défi
soit impossible à relever mais je pense
que ça c'est quelque chose qui va être
compliqué dans dans la gestion de la
contrainte et gérer ça de manière douce
et est à mon avis un vrai défi alors je
vais je vais en profiter pour faire une
suggestion
je trouve dommage qu'aujourd'hui dans un
certain nombre de disciplines des
sciences sociales
il n'y ait personne donc je parle pas
que tout le monde se convertissaient ce
que je vais dire mais cueillez pas au
moins 5 % des gens qui ceux qui
réfléchissent en se disant admettons que
l'hypothèse de départ c'est que demain
y'a pas plus mais moins comment je gère
ça au mieux alors je trouve pas normal
que dans le monde des économistes les
personnes qui travaillent avec ça comme
données de départ
leur seule question c'est comment je
vais revenir la croissance mais comment
je gère un monde dans lequel parce que
ça dépend pas de moi ça revient pas et
[Musique]
vous les cherchez quoi y'en a pas eh
bien c'est exactement pareil dans le
monde psychologique et sociologique
je pense que la meilleure manière de
s'accommoder de la contrainte dans une
société humaine
je trouve alors évidemment je trouvais
que le sujet n'est pas très sexy
moi je pense qu'il a eue d'utilité
sociale majeure parce que c'est avec ça
qu'on va trouver des recettes de cuisine
qui nous seront extrêmement utiles pour
savoir comment est ce qu'on arrive au
mieux à gérer le monde tel qu'il est et
non pas le monde tel qu'on voudrait
qu'il soit ça me fait vraiment penser à
aurélie piette cet économiste qui vient
de sortir un livre dont je me souviens
plus le nom parce qu'il est très très
long comme c'est à la mode
le livre le titre le livre et le titre
mais le livre est passionnant et
je pense que vous auriez beaucoup
beaucoup échangé ensemble et on suivait
notre prochain rendez-vous des futurs
tout cas le 20 mai vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure en parlant d' art vous avez
parlé de bd vous avez parlé de cinéma
cinéma ça vous a titillé vous y
reviendrai peut-être d'ailleurs la
musique ça vous a jamais titiller
puisqu'on a évidemment une chronique
musicale juste derrière dans les
versions modernes de la danse de la
pluie le fait que je me batte à chanter
donc non pour pas donc il n'y a pas que
je touchais ça bon on passe à la
dernière chronique la chronique musicale
de charlie et on se retrouve pour le mot
de la fin
[Musique]
alors le thème imposé aujourd'hui pour
cette chronique musicale c'est l'énergie
alors on va essayer de répondre en trois
morceaux choisis avec amour l'énergie
l'énergie l'énergie alors créé peut-être
ou jouer de la musique autrement
ah oui tiens ça me fait penser à un
artiste français qui s'amuse de la
musique électronique en sans plan des
bruits qui l'entourent
ça peut être de l'eau qui coule ça peut
être le froissement d'un papier le
rebond d'une balle de ping pong et les
enregistre durant son live en fait des
boucles et les ajoute au fur et mesure
ce n'est pas révolutionnaire d'autres
l'ont fait mais c'est plutôt sympa à
écouter c'est plutôt plaisant
il s'appelle jacques et l'a extrait
qu'on vantant ses feux de choses un live
loupe à l'amour
[Musique]
non
et dans le genre récup et pourquoi pas
jouer de la techno mais sans technologie
il ya un type qui s'appelle 'pape gaye
il vit en australie et à force de voir
des vidéos de blue man group un groupe
du luberon lui qui se peignent tout en
bleu et qui ont créé un instrument de
musique à la base à base de pvc qu'ils
ont dénommée le tube l'homme lui s'est
lancé
c'est assez simple il s'installe dans la
rue avec une caisse pour les rythmes des
tubes en pvc et à 1 ghz deux baguettes
des tongs
oui c'est bien ça et ça donne ça et
accessoirement sa petite vidéo là qu'on
entend et qu'on va voir
elle a fait 53 millions du sûr sur
youtube c'est assez bluffant
voilà qu'on peut faire la techno sans
électricité et pour finir va changer
complètement d'univers
on va peut-être s'intéresser à notre
propre énergie
voilà des émotions comment gérer tout ça
on va aller vers quelque chose de plus
peut-être qu'ils se rapprochent plus
peut-être de la méditation ou je ne sais
c'est un projet qui s'appelle abou sadia
c'est un projet qui a été menée par le
quart élitiste et saxophoniste franco
tunisien yassin boularès il revisite le
stambali qui est une musique de transe
et de guérison qui avait été écrit par
lady c'est mon descendants des esclaves
subsahariens a mené en tunisie et il a
fait jouer cela crée ce projet avec le
violoncelliste vincent segal et le
batteur américain nasheet waits ça donne
ça le morceau là qu'on entend c'est
d'art chems autrement dit la maison du
soleil
quelque chose de se livrer au
[Musique]
oh
merci beaucoup charlie merci pour cette
pour cette séquence qui est un vrai
rendez vous dans nos rendez-vous des
futures bon on a ouvert plein de
fenêtres évidemment on n'est pas rentré
totalement dans chaque dans chaque rayon
si si le mot de la fin vous appartenez
ce serait quoi qu'il n'y a pas de fin
c'est plutôt un début on pourra parler
du mot de la fin quand et aura une fin
mais un commencement du commencement oui
on est au commencement du commencement
encore une fois on doit apprendre une
nouvelle histoire
la nouvelle histoire qu'on doit
apprendre c'est comment on a foi en
l'avenir et quel genre de projets
positifs on peut mettre en oeuvre dans
un monde dans lequel s'est plus
l'expansion qu'il règle merci beaucoup
jean marc jancovici merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation des rendez vous du
futur
cette émission a été préparée du coup
par triple cjd carré le cube
merci à gwendal marcon pour ses
questionnements qui m'ont un petit peu
alimenté les prochains rendez vous vous
sortez vos québec sq d'habitude le 20
mai prochain du kun spéciale à bordeaux
on fera escale là bas avec aurélie
piette donc je vous enverrai c'est son
livre nicolas thierry vice président du
conseil régional de l aquitaine et puis
avec six actrices du changement vous
allez voir ça va être une émission
vraiment décapante le 20 mai le 4 juin
avec pascal picq ce sera ici le taux
juin c'est l'émission spéciale dans le
cadre du forum changer d'air la cité des
sciences et de l'industrie
merci à tous suivez nos invités suivez
notre invité suivez leur projet et a
tout de suite sur les réseaux merci
[Musique]